what up reject nation greg john and coy big miss
marvel fan over here she's a great character
she's a great character we're going to watch miss
marvel episode 2 today very excited to check it
out this is a quick heads up full length watch
along where you sing up with the timecode for
a super sexy rejects over our patreon page cover
a bunch of stuff over there as well leave a like
that would be very much appreciated and your
thoughts down below on this episode subscribe and
click that bell to get notified when our reaction
for the next miss marvel episode is up and then
boys at prepper thanks for helping us edit down
these highlights lastly i want to genuinely thank
athletic greens for partnering up with us since
the last time we mentioned athletic greens like
i've been in the middle of moving hopefully by the
time this video's out i've already moved and so
there's been a lot of stuff coming out so there's
been like barely any sleep to occur however and he
will attest i've been drinking athletic greens
every single day and it has genuinely helped so
we're going to talk more about them uh after the
reaction but yeah i just wanted to say thank you
because having some brand partnerships lately
has really been helping out with uh hiring some
extra help and some other people and i'm going
to steal a sample hiring to pay other people
you know what i love about airpods that you
don't have to stand that's close by each other
i am so sorry no worries
make a move because the videos you sent
me were just flashes of pink light and i
didn't see anything you didn't see anything i
tried to shrink and and fly and talk to ants
and then if it worked i mean she had physical
contact with the superhero obviously people are
going to be interested it's because like she
knew that like i could be the one to handle
oh my god and then this like beautiful white
light like cascaded over me i knew i was sick
there's another superhero catastrophe and
she's sitting there bragging about being
saved by the budget captain marvel thank
you thank you yeah someone finally said
which is why i'm gonna have a party on friday
you know to celebrate the fragility of life
nice yeah we're so not going to that party well
i'm having a party on friday you should come
yeah no that sounds really fun actually yeah
thank you cool we should be at that party
what oh poor brew now guy in the chair
so i guess super strength is
not a part of the equation
i saved you
only because you almost killed me first still
counts okay maybe i do need to work on my skills
i don't stay put i stay grind
training montage yes singular push-up montage
damn how do you shoot that yeah that's
this could say there's a lot of like
really subtly impressive effect shots
oh my is perfect for this toned show
tone show this tone of show no m.i.a like totally
fits this world yeah this tone show tone show
tone locks brother tone show tough love
god even i know you're being too lucky
you really gotta fix this place
the men's section is pristine
no talking during the lecture please sorry
shake up the light you know it's just
really hard to concentrate when
we can barely see you sister
the partition and the side
entrance are there to preserve
all our modesty and dignity thank
you sister kamala for reminding us
that it is important to share your voice
though perhaps except during my lecture
and another reminder nominations are still
open for the most part election oh my god
do i look like a nine-year-old man to you no
no no no no no come on somebody stole my
shoes when you versace's maybe we'll run
for the moss board and actually make some
change around here yeah your sheets got
nothing on you baby okay you're the change the
change is here and the change is her everyone
so that is graffiti last time zoey's
having some people over tonight
bruno and akio will both be
there and i'll be home by nine
but this time you see that you come back through
the door bring hulk down yes always bring up that
even like beyond the emotionality connection
like the casting is visually great too like
everyone looks like both their age and their
like family yeah that looks just like her mom
very true man is there alcohol on that no it's
just orange juice sure dude why would you do
the that that's not cool what's maneuver
no we can't everyone's here including us
don't jump dudes
oh is that new boy yeah yeah it's
new boy that's a good way to die
nope great way to make an entrance too
look at this guy she's subtle
she's drunk marvel body shots
i can't do time okay guys i have a call so
everyone just called me everyone at the party
q7 getting my small sports car so cool i love
the color he seems so serious at high school
he's a senior what she did you
backed up into the car remember
thanks bryn i almost forgot about that it's fine
i failed my first time as well so you could just
drive my car so i figured out you'll figure it out
do you like watching bollywood movies and stuff
uh obviously but only the greats like why's it go
all the other stuff like that i mean it doesn't
surprise you like basketball it's only srk's best
word yeah srk your opinion says ddlj of course
right there i watched it a few years back it was
very pleasing great critical analysis very
pleasing i'm very put that on the poster
here's my number give me a text or drop me a
call make sure i can save yours as well and uh
yeah what a nice guy it's great meeting
you guys um miguel paul nakia ryan
we don't talk about brewing no i'm
gonna talk about brian for sure
out of everything is great
that is a great fade yeah oh
how is zoe's house oh it's magical
love the subjectivity the reality
those are some great effects i love the
use of digital in the world it's so cool
oh my my whole life i've either been too
white for some people or too ethnic for others
and it's been this very i can relate with that
i kind of realized i don't really need to
prove anything to anybody like when i put
this on i feel like me like i have a purpose
probably why i ran for the mosque board
remember you're the one who convinced me
to do it in the first place i love you
oh um i got you something for your driving lesson
i feel like this is her first job like she's very
good yeah yeah oh all my dreams are coming true
hello to see hearns and dana interact
and florence today from euphoria
you're sitting down
the early immersion program at caltech you
got it cal tech i don't know what to say
you say yes can i think about it okay bruno
you know that part in the movie where someone
comes in to the main character and they say
you want to be a jedi you want to answer phones
have a demanding but impossibly chic magazine
well that's this moment that is
happening to you right now you're
the lead character i'm meryl streep unleash
your inner hat away but it's in california
away from kamala
oh okay hi my name is yeah you good
ducky i can't really train today what why
oh um i'll see you later okay oh buddy just build
some tech to kill this guy man we're just gonna
become the villain are you sure yeah de-stress
after school first thing you can do drive bruh
now that bro so cool don't
tell me you have a massive
crush on keto too my um uh my
mom just literally upset me
and that's great still has a huge crush on king
or senior yeah concerning several kingdoms anthony
oh shoot why are we my brother and
this beyonce he's going to freak out
okay and then i'm going to freak out
a great frame
oh
brother sister this is comrade
he's our cousin he's source
is from pakistan how come you have a
british accent oh i'm a huge fan of
the great british bake off i love that show i
just binged it so i was just doing a bit oh man
okay we should go i think i remember you man some
things on the internet we called you haram.com ron
i'm gonna call you that from
now on all right dude all right
all right oh no it wasn't a goth phase oh yeah
i just wore a lot of black that's why we moved
to america right so that our children could be
anything that they wanted to be almost anything
anything with our strict approval not a superhero
every pakistani family has a partition story
and none of them are good enough this is not
about the partition okay this is a celebration
makes sense why they fear so much for
safety all the time uniba's mother
she got separated from her parents on the train
station nobody knows how that little toddler
sunnah managed to get back on the tree just
before the train pulled out of the station
sana always said that she
followed a trail of stars
where can i see a trail of stars at some point
wowie
so like the history remains imbued in there
like an anime what the bengal it does some
really weird things and and that belongs
to my mother aisha the one who disappeared
during politician my great-grandmother faisha
but no i've spoken too much already no no oh oh
so this belonged to aisha and you really
have no idea what happened to her oh
dang
sorry
hey don't question my love for the captain kid
if it wasn't for slippery when wet your father
and i may never have met oh yeah that was gross
there's that jersey culture do you know
what happened to our great grandma aisha
where did you hear that name from nani brought
shame on our entire family please let it go
damn but that happened i don't know you it
looks so great because it's not too um right
i don't understand the questions
that you have to make it
past the mini girls and blast
the ones who know it all and will
not let you forget it the illuminati
just murks them all on the spot
she's helping me exercise our
right as citizens of this great nation to
participate in democracy it's wonderful
wouldn't rob two young women
of that future would you uncle i mean
come on this is kamala and me commona khan
how are we today miss uh zimmer is this about
the party because it really was not that loud
you're not the zoe zimmer the only one i know
what you have got to be kidding i'm a big fan
oh my gosh this guy's [__] well i'm so
glad you liked it and you went to avenger
con oh my gosh you must been mobbed by all
your fans no no you have a good time it was
this guy's great i i didn't really get a good
look at her i mean it all happened so fast
did she have an accent no was she latina
i'm sorry i'm supposed to say latinx now right
debatably middle eastern perhaps south asian
you're doing a bad job this is my thing oh your
great grandmother my father called her a snake
she put a curse on everything she touched curse
heard she had many affairs and she had a secret
family i heard she killed a man dead happened
during partition i'm sure she wasn't that bad
that's not gonna go down
all the avengers show up there's one little boy
hey hey where's going uh i think
she went home with her parents
nah oh i thought they're gonna do okay this
works so he's got it with her yo it's night life
nightlight all the way up here why did i do this
it's good it's good exposition
kid it's a good question script
do you have a favorite food ice cream
pizza she's going to say please help him
is that two foods or one food one i put ice
cream on pizza does anyone say ice cream pizza
start selling that at my stand
trail of stars
oh my god [__]
superhero landing you better get him
off that platform yep he's gonna panic
wowie
when you fall down trees yep
you just hope it's enough
how could she do that she clearly
didn't try to save him afterwards
good sound effects you know got
a little glass sound little point
oh wow hold right where you are
oh damn
get in come on come on i've
been waiting a very long time
i'd like you to meet my mom they are related
wowie you remember when you googled and the name
popped up and i went oh no because it taught me
way too much that was the moment oh really yeah
that's a big character from like a recent arc
they did it way early i'm sorry that google
google telling me names wait so they are related
in a way and he's another
character too he's not just
that character my main concern is
like where are the relationships
i don't care about spoilers i saw some hand
holders oh yes hey she was sent to him and
he seemed into her he said they travel a lot it
sounded like they had something to do with you
know shenanigans they were up to some shenanigans
i thought it was just like real estate problems
i know that he stays up who stays title now we
wait for a post credit scene they might be here
guys i took my headphones off last time i was
foolish you're supposed to be the marvel guy
you're supposed to know when there's post-credits
scenes i'm sorry that was ruined for you
it was just so you saw a twist coming yeah because
i read the comics like a fool that's your fault
man stupid no post criticism we're not real marvel
why'd we wait you're not a real mcu yeah really
you would give us a bunch of stuff in the credits
department of damage controls were grooting
avengers the dark ones yeah yeah yeah they should
cut spiderman that's what they're doing i'm pretty
sure that's what's happening the dark avengers
are getting formed by the girl from seinfeld
all right guys i don't have time for cory's
jokes anymore let's talk about this seriously
all right well i'm sure john and coy have a lot
of thoughts and i have thoughts too but before
we go into those thoughts if you want to feel
like a superhero you should listen to a work
from our sponsor today thank you to athletic
greens for partnering up with us this month well
the schedule is wild as ours it's tough to stay on
top of proper diet and nutrition luckily athletic
green's eg1 formula makes your daily nutrition
simple delicious inconvenient get bigger just one
scoop contains 75 high quality vitamins minerals
probiotics and a whole bunch more which supports
gut health nervous and immune systems energy focus
plus on a serious note ag-1 is lifestyle friendly
i'm actually allergic to dairy so any shake i
ever have has to be dairy-free so whether you eat
keto paleo vegan dairy-free or gluten-free it's a
good fit plus it's completely natural no harmful
chemicals or gmos and for my sake it helps to
improve my sleep quality and mental clarity which
is always a boost it helps improve my gut health
i like to poop and i like saving money and what's
great about athletic greens is your subscription
only costs about three dollars a day that's double
what i paid john and it comes with a year supply
of vitamin d and all that is way cheaper than
trying to get all these supplements individually
so head on over to athleticgreens.com regex to
start your ag1 lifestyle today no seriously thank
you athletic greens you guys uh that that stuff
that's really has been very you've been drinking
it too lately don i subscribed did you myself
i'm going to try this stuff i'm saying when
it's done sold on it when we're when we're done
with our partnership athletic greens i am no
longer drinking now i'm actually i like their
stuff a lot yeah it's a big help i i genuinely
talk about energy built it into my day you saw
me before we filmed i actually pay attention today
look at you i'm often tired lethargic and i need
more athletic greens well maybe you don't eat taco
bell before you show up you know what happens when
you live next to a weekend there's tons of greens
in it frisco guys we need to focus cory gets paid
by the second second here it's not brought to you
by taco bell john why don't you go first i enjoyed
this continuing developing installment of the
story this feels like a very natural progression
certain of the marvel tv series feel more smooth
than others and thus far this feels like a very
smooth feed from first episode into the second
episode i really do feel like i'm watching a
movie progress in installments in a lot of ways
and i very much appreciate that and i mean here
it kind of did what i was hoping last time where
it seems like we're diving closer and closer into
her past and her heritage and where those powers
are tied to that obviously setting up to the
greater world stakes of what the dodc is able to
do in interfering and regulating and containing
what kamala is up to and yeah i've been loving
the growth of the characters and the way that
they're able to balance out you know the on the
ground level stuff like with nakia running for um
you know for for uh uh mosque board
and all that stuff and everything feels
proportionate and everything feels alive and yeah
it doesn't feel like the big marvelly stuff is
competing with the story stuff yo john i totally
agree with you on everything i think you said
um what really dawned on me this time have you
seen the movie turning red yeah i enjoyed it
have you seen turning red i have not but i'll
watch it along with you on patreon when i do
that yeah this is how many fandoms do i have to
be 100 dedicated to all of them have you been
on the internet there are a lot of qualities
of this that are kind of like turning red yeah
i also think it's a really useful way of telling
uh a unique story in a familiar way like we said
in the first episode that kind of escalated
here much like turning red yes well also like
with the family history the lineage the pair the
parental stuff like there's a lot that feels very
similar in terms of except with the whole like
you know she doesn't turn into a big panda here
or does she does she will see guys we saw
that thing with the nose she might become a
panda in the end a big cosmic panda this is why i
usually lead these because i have the smart things
i mean the guy top of them my brain has an
extra wrinkle like there's no point in you
stop watching they just stopped all the
corrective takes that we need to hear what i find
very fast about the quality of this show a lot
of the times they'll start implementing heritage
cultures other qualities and a lot of times that
feels like backdrop or secondary both of these
episodes the high school quality the heritage
the culture all those things that usually feel
secondary are so primary that i'll forget that
oh yeah this is a superhero show they come in
so much later in both of these episodes the first
episode thought okay all right so we set it all up
we got that crazy ending cool now let's go
gung-ho superhero not really like you do some
of the training which kind of felt like shazam
a little bit yeah that's some gym gentlemen
are you referring to dc's captain marvel oh
that's ironic i like that nicely done nicely done
because shazam was named captain marvel but then
there was legal issues where they couldn't use the
name captain marvel but then at the end of the day
technically he's still called captain marvel even
though miss marvel and you know captain marvel
of the one she admires is also the same name as
the shazam character of which we're referring this
guy is so aware he gets paid by the minute shazam
was the word i was trying to say i was trying to
speed up but then greg gave crap so i was trying
to be helpful but no no since he interrupted
i had to explain the joke that was very
this whole thing about shazam and captain
marvel i didn't know what to be mad about
no you're not he wants to be mad it was a
legal issue when they both had two characters
i just need to know what to be outraged about
just pick something and go and this point someone
will join her in that computer screen yeah
i think feigned outrage would really help us
blow up that's how we get there guys we haven't
tried it in two years marvel forcing this female
perspective on me man oh man is there a girl one
out of 37 properties is mgu now that we've had
four women as leads out of 37 films they're
clearly adjusting for half the population
roughly 52 percent there's only one white guy and
he's just a friend and he has extraordinary smarts
frankly demoralizing and imagine the white man
look you guys go way off topic too much and i'm
sorry for setting you up to be off topic you've
given up get back on the tracks people here we go
i agree with you john it does it does feel like
because this is not the most cinematic of them all
in terms of although there's an argument to
be made for that i would say i think it's
more cinematic than a lot of them because it's
so stylized and the quality of the imagery and
they and the way they implement the effects of
being because they this show does such a good
job at thrusting you into her perspective that's
when they go all like whack-a-doodle-do with the
visuals that i think are so beautiful to look at
and times i like when they like sneak up on you
when you don't see the visuals like like the bad
one yeah that was one of my favorites that was
so pretty and it also feels like a comic book
because a lot of times the comic book imagery
looks scott pilgrim it comes out of nowhere or
it's really subtly in there but this has so many
frames that are existing simultaneously that it
feels like a comic book frame where you can add in
some onomatopoeias some descriptive dialogue
some because you can't have a text sound in a
comic book because it's a page so i love that they
have this imagery that feels like it's right from
the books i think this is a pretty solid show so
far sometimes i do find myself a bit craving a lo
maybe because i've been conditioned i do wonder
that about myself cause i'm so used to like we're
sitting down here we're gonna watch a superhero
show so sometimes i expect a little bit more of
that superhero umph i don't really know if that's
a problem for me or if that's just my preconceived
notions about thinking we're last left off so
we're probably gonna go gung-ho superhero because
i'm actually enjoying it when i when i forget
about that and then i get lost in you know like
the storyline of uh uh what was her name and that
was probably that's for the mosque isn't it nakia
i don't know you're more likely what does it mean
because i don't know if i'm getting confused with
black panther's nokia but i thought that was it is
pronounced because i've only ever read it but it's
spelled n-i-k-i-a i believe yeah okay microphone
oh it's a microphone here we are this is this yeah
that storyline i find really fascinating and
and it seems like they're really going to tie
it all together though it is still going to
be like the superhero show because clearly
all this stuff that the mom is kind of clued
in on about mystical past and whatever and why
it seems to be a bit of this thing where she's so
dismayed by the concept of superheroes it seems so
tied in yeah it seems so tied into wherever
her pain stems from and getting this uh
what is the word uh the not what
the p word what was it the pair
the the when they're talking about the past
the pair oh the partition partition partition
the partition thank you john thank you john for
being the word guy i got some words more than us
yeah yeah be the be the thought guy what's up
what's going on there at the end without spoiling
too without spoiling too much because we we were
looking up the cast and there's a character which
we met this episode who is many things in the
comic books and i will say without giving away
too much he's not just the person we've met he is
also another character who i really enjoy from the
comic books and i do believe if they go with the
storyline i think they're taking this on which is
a more recent arc there's going to be a twist on
the twist we just got things aren't as they seem
even in the like there's a double agent situation
perhaps being unfolded i'm trying not to give
anything away so people aren't like ah spoilers
for in the comics but there is an opportunity for
us to have a a twist on the twist with a dual
identity of this other guy if they do that
but what i think the show one of the things i'm
finding the strength of is where we had the falcon
winter soldier show kind of being a backdoor
pilot for the dark avengers or thunderbolts
whichever way they take it we had you know a
darker captain america we had you know the the
assembly that brought us a new black widow those
things this very much feels like they're going to
use the dodc to kind of radicalize the champions
aka and i think the young avengers so in the
comics you've got two different teams there's the
new avengers as well as the dark avengers there's
also the dark avengers as well as the thunderbolts
and those both separately could exist but with
movies and things you don't want to confuse the
audience so i do i do think they're gonna kind
of bring these chunks of characters together
into one unit like i was saying last episode
uh champions are very important in street level
but i do think they're going to kind of make the
young avengers and the champions into one thing
i think they're going to kind of summarize up
that world so i do think while we're getting one
team of adult dark avengers or thunderbolts we're
also getting a radicalized more politicized more
street level team of kids that are going to have
a lot to come from because if you look at what
just happened to wanda's kids if they get those
powers that's going to be hugely important we've
also got kate bishop who's been when like you know
organized crime she's going to be like street
level but you know going through these things
we've met like seven of these children who've
all gone through these traumatic events and now
kamala's going through it with a legal side so
i do think we're gearing up towards a team of
younger child avengers who have all been through
trauma but also we're gonna be having to fight
the man itself like we're gonna be fighting the
government they're gonna be active fighting law
and i think that's where we're going to get
the she-hulk and daredevils and such that i was
alluding to last week but more as a team i could
see an entire like young avengers movie be about
like you know their civil war and it looks like
we're going there with the dodc can kids be heroes
the question is like who's at fault if you're 15
or 16 and you cause damage like think about it
they're the department of damage control you can't
sue a child or you sue the parent is the parent
if they don't know what fault is it evil legally
acceptable for someone to be you know i mean like
there's so many ramifications of a child putting
on a mask does a child have rights at a point like
does a child have the ability to use those powers
and i do think long term i don't think it's going
to lead directly into but i do think that's going
to lead to the world that hates and fears this
fears them that gets this x-men because right
now everyone loves heroes everyone looks i mean
there's an avengers con we need there to be a
point where it makes sense that some heroes are
hated and feared and i think the dark avengers is
going to go the adult x-men route but i do think
planning the legal seeds with the champions and
young avengers gives us both paths to x-men yeah
you know i could see some of that subtle shades
here what's the dodc what's his department of
damage control no no no no no no no what's the
guy's name don't remember he's not direct from
the comics to be honest he seems like he
just has to stick up his ass all the time
man just trying to hunt down kids just hates
kids every time he turns guys hates kids he's
like you're the worst person ever right that's how
he talks and terry you know it sucks you i love it
having them in there department damage control and
then also even the way how she is with her powers
uh because already he's like you guys are doing
some messed up things yeah influencer wannabe
chick and then zoey who's her name zoe and then at
the end there even with the little boy just like
theorizing here along with what you're bringing
up even with the little boy uh who uh kamala saved
clearly she slipped up but from their perspective
they're all like why did she do that ankle yeah
his ankle is damaged now so she like hurt
this boy so it's looked like this person's not
good or this person shouldn't be a hero
or this person shouldn't be doing this
um so yeah i think what you're at least talking
about there seems to be some shades that seem to
allude to such a thing john i've got a question
for you yes sir has i pitched the ball to you
i'm here and i'm getting ready for you to
i got my mitt swing away merrell all right
we're talking about twists and twists on twists
when are we going to get a shyamalan directed
episode when all the twists come i mean he
almost played doctor strange joaquin i was like
who is your favorite character outside
of kamala khan oh that's a tough question
probably the dad was great is delightful i like
uh naki a lot and i like that they gave them
a really solid i think that was this episode
i think they gave them a really solid
you know female friendship like a real intimate
moment of friendship and of them just conferring
about like how do you do it how do you make all
this growth and this weirdness look easy and i
think their bond together is something really
nice and special i like that it seems like they
are paying attention to that storyline where she's
running for mosque board i like her a lot i think
she's great and i like what those characters what
she does for kamala what she brings out of kamala
and what she represents for the show as a whole
uh and just the kind of conversations that come
up through her so i think that's probably my
second favorite character so far bruno for you
uh you know i love bruno mainly because he is
flirty like me as we discussed last week yeah
and white and white no uh i really like uh how
do they pronounce his name because again i always
read the dude in the car the cool guy the new
guy cameron cameron i just wanted to get it right
as i could uh come run i i don't know if i love
him because of uh what i think they're doing or
you know i mean like there's a thing that i think
they're doing and if they do it they are having
fun watching you wriggle right now because they
know that you know but maybe you don't i'm trying
not to i'm trying to not be the guy but like at
the same time if they do what i think they're
gonna do there's a reason the accent switched
there's a reason uh he is a hyphen in his credit
there's there's if they do what they're doing
it's a really fun way to manipulate the story in
a way that we haven't seen in a lot of superhero
properties and he's really like fun and charming
without it feeling lecherous which i think
we might need a koi's comic before episode
three comes out we could do how we might get
dark avengers thunderbolts and young avengers
champions leading up to x-men and all that things
what a great efficient title just start a board
keywords title dark avengers and champions
and young avengers and go do you have a marvel
question it's the next week's topic on koi's comic
corner guys want no shortage of possibilities
organizations we're getting like we're getting
like the dodc feels very established we've got
that you know the different parts of the world are
getting more flesh out than just shield especially
since shield's been dismantled was kind of like
rumbling back and things it's because the first
you know three phases were kind of just hydra
versus shield and bad guys this is uh there's
a lot more layers to the world especially
the shows yeah yeah there's a lot going on
there's so many things happening because if you
think about it right now they just had hawkeye
take on the the tracksuit mafia which felt like
it was down the street which is fun we've got all
the things happening with the tva and loki which
is another organization we've got all the things
happening in the movies with like the magic
groups and those organizations we've also got
the ideals of the celestials thanks to the
eternals and those greater cosmic organizations
and then we've also got like the reality of what
we're dealing with in like the street level heroes
fighting villains that we haven't even met
yet plus all the time variance authority stuff
interacting with the small global it's gonna
be crazy and i do think we're leaning towards
basically like moon knight-esque uh blade
characters they're gonna leave the occult
thanks to the st stuff that happens girl at
witch so like lots of tea it's like a comic
book and then we also have evangeline lily being
anti-vaxx and that's a problem for all of us they
should make a team out of all the actors in the
mcu who are anti-vaxx and who definitely have
not affected any of their productions not
a one you know what i want you know what i
also appreciated here was the amount of kingo
call-outs oh man every time this is filming
career chuckle yeah that's right good [__] nice
little bollywood because he was like like i like
king go senior and stuff they were saying that
like they have no idea that it's the same guy
and they were like oh how could you
even like it's like all kamel nanjani
so so genius i did like the i do like bruno
a lot i feel i i feel like he's a really
solid character felt like i wasn't allowed to
say so why you know like you like it because
despite all the evidence of good acting work
and some some decent writing charming and he's
actually very good at playing the guy in the
chair but still being like i like that he's a
guy in the chair and he's so supportive that is
like genuinely like never never does the cliche
of he's not the dude from my big fat greek wedding
he's not who's like well this is all kind of weird
and wacky to me he's genuinely has a vested
interest in everything around him and he's he's
he uh he there's a lot of admiration and respect
and wants to understand in a way that feels very
genuine and natural and i feel like that's how you
do supportive white guy you know how and sometimes
when you like a character too much you got to
worry about him i'm not saying he's going to die
but i'm not saying you shouldn't worry about it
you think bruno is going to die i think bruno's
got some bruno is not going to die he's going
to die i'm just saying i'm worried about him
no one's going to die in this show i'm just saying
i'm working everyone's gonna live twice this is
just saying i'm worried about him i mean i am a
little bit worried about bruno but i don't know i
i mostly i don't know mostly i just appreciate too
that it doesn't i feel like the whole thing where
he clearly has either is very protective of her
or is just straight crushing on her i like that
the way they've played that too because while
it's not like the most revolutionary take on that
i feel like they've played it in a way that is
remarkably un annoying and wrote like that's
something that could very easily become like a
ah come on dude like this is kind of an annoying
cliche archetype without being played cliche
like yeah it's a thing we've seen before but
he's doing it naturalistically yeah he makes a
good ducky yeah a lot to say about the white guy
you know what i'm just saying he's the minority
of this show you laugh because i know that you're
both getting your heads about the white guys
i'm just aware this makes me laugh so much and
i'm like something dude just put the pressure
on us just put the pressure on us greg here we
are all right can i just come out and say that
he's my favorite character and i don't really
care about any of this other [__] we could
get out of kamala's life and into his life
can we also like the bracelet i want to challenge
the world for a second though the music is such
a beautiful way to tie you into like the feeling
of being in a different world because like a lot
of the marvel shows they use scores they use they
don't really have soundtracks that i would like to
listen to like whereas this is a lot of stuff that
feels like you can just like actually i'd play the
miss marvel soundtrack which i don't say about
the other shows really a lot of the times it's
like what sounds like r b music to me whatever
whatever nowadays these days are listening to
the the rap music but it's whatever but it's not
no it's not it's the same thing rhythm and blues
either a country classic rocker rap the
pop music landscape at this moment in time
pretty much encompasses r b and hip-hop
radio stations country not country r b
that's basically what pop music is right now
those three things what you're talking about
koi you don't understand anything you only
like mgk uh so he's two genres on his own
excuse me coulson baker i'm trying to say that
what they do here is they have a lot of great
soundtracks yeah but a lot of times it's not
american soundtracks too and i think that's it's
cool to like get that familiarity with something
different for someone who is uninitiated and a lot
of the group what i don't know the artist or what
they're playing i'm like i would put this stuff on
it's in similar ways though i feel a lot of people
maybe discover how k-pop has become such a a crazy
part of the world now that it's like i know so
many people are into k-pop who don't speak korean
and now listening to a lot of the the music here
i'm getting that same effect of like damn i would
just put this on and i have no idea what they're
saying greg just said what i said while making fun
of me he literally just took the immersive quality
of my compliment about the music but decided to
make it about him making fun of me on the journey
cory you're so self-centered i just i i have no
idea what you said because i was thinking about
what i was going to have yeah here we are i just
appreciate that they gave the sweatshop boys a
direct call out director good for the sweatshirt
direct call out and m.i.a i haven't heard in
years used in pop culture so i'm very excited
yeah pineapple express that was like two years
ago brandon just dropped a new song i like the
show a lot it's in my upper half of the marvel
show so far i i put it like obviously until it's
done i don't know how it's going to stick
the landing but i've been really impressed
number one marvel show
white guild's coming through
you know i said it's better than most of the
movies it's better than most of the comics
here we are yeah because we have the mean koi
of the most to make up for because we're not
only white but we're dudes yeah we got all
this stuff the ethnic one you're like i'll
be the dumb one in the video you're over here
being like oh i recognize parts of mike he's
over here mia rnb and he's getting away with it
they are gonna get away with it emma is a person
m.i.a watches this channel all right
m.i.a is a big fan yeah i love that song
take your money float like a butterfly
yeah it's actually a biographical
song about muhammad ali oh my god
the mia covered that song the
m in mia and the a is for ali
the lyrics are actually her saying
what she's describing all i want to
do is know his gun who's going to his cash
register she basically wants to roll up
fire a few shots and take
your money she'll rob you
it's a joyous anthem of robbing someone else
while being muhammad ali's and bones success
three categories of music everyone which
aeronautical pop song are we drawing from people
paper planes john denver songs here's this is
you know what's great is that we can have this
conversation there's a lot of very culturally
inspired pop music in the show that gives us the
chance to go dive into some of this music and find
a new fixation or find a new song that we enjoy
much like kamala's family shares their love
of their adopted bon jovi museum prince
jersey prince bonnie j i loved hearing bon jovi
referenced in the marvel cinematic universe as
beyonce was in doctor street people are
going to click on this video man like
wow their video is an hour and a half they must
have broken this down but to the team little
did they know easter eggs we're talking about
jefferson airplane airplanes and paper planes
for quite some time r b all of it guys i thought
it greens keeps you sharp focused energetic and
ready unlock your inner superhero with a delicious
helping over 75 delicious vitamins and minerals
you don't know this is what the surrounding area
looks like right now what matters is i'm awake
in spite of everything and that's all thanks
to athletic greens and i'm still enjoying this
show a lot dave what's her name kamala khan
actors uh yeah come on john come on johnny
nice yeah you're gonna meet her one day
probably interview and be like hey you're great
yeah that's the whole interview it's going
to go well i'm going to bring up mia would
you do to be great do you like mia's r b album it
should be like who are you old man please do that
please i'm 45 years old give me a break which
i've come a long way i know your kids are
neglected we need to go check on them that's
why he's moving he's leaving him here oh god
yeah they're awful the worst abandon your children
at all costs anyway guys are you abandoned leave
your thoughts down below this went off the rails
a long time ago we're going to go now in a second
john what are you doing down
here shut up oh my god flip
you have the imagination and the enthusiasm
and if anybody is gonna become somebody super
duper in your part of the world
save the people of romania from
certain destruction and conventions gone awry
it's gonna be you buddy you bring me such joy
and wonder but inside i know there's a
yearning to unlock something deeper you
could do it buddy you can do it just pump it and
write it and and everything you just spin on it
just spit on it lube it up lev we love
you and uh and stay well out there